las vegas now host mercedes martinez
helping us rise and shine live this
morning from the mix 941 studio good
morning mercedes
good morning john today the theme of our
rise and shine segment is kid
and baby videos who wouldn't want to
smile about that we start with a stone
cold toddler one-year-old emperor is
running to the front porch as her very
excited grandma waits without stretched
arms but
the girl is not interested
she dodges nana and runs inside calling
for papa the family got quite the
chuckle about the little girl's cold
shoulder to grandma this video was
actually taken back in may but it's now
going viral with more than 2 million
views on youtube
now next up this adorable tick tock
video of baby with man's best friend as
you can see toby loves the little baby
and is very protective he doesn't want
to even let mama touch the baby pawing
her hand every single time that she
reaches for him he's like no my baby
stay awake
they get very loyal those dogs i love
the adorable videos you see online of
dogs getting nestled up with like
newborn children and stuff like that
getting to know them and smell them and
everything it's a beautiful thing
and it's so cute and then the baby's
just laying there with its bottle like
yeah everybody loves me it's all good
and meanwhile finally mercedes that kid
needs to get onto the football field
that little juke there to get around
grandma that was some special stuff yeah
a little shoulder shitty there good move
i know i love it mercedes thank you very
much have a good rest of the day we'll
catch up with you later this week
appreciate it